Belarus we're political allies have
jailed opposition leader Maria
colesnikova say that she has been
hospitalized and that she remains in
intensive care
kalisticova's father says that she was
taken to the emergency unit and
underwent surgery but he says there were
no further details
she's 40 years old and she was part of a
trio of prominent women who led historic
demonstrations against belarus's leader
Alexander lukashenko and she was jailed
after she spectacularly resisted
expulsion from her own country by
destroying in public her passport
foreign
for the Belarusian opposition he joins
me tonight from Vilnius in Lithuania
it's good to see you again
um what are you hearing about your
colleague and friend Maria
we all are praying for her health for
her life we found out about the
situation just a few hours ago I was
with satana we were shocked she was a
very close friend and Ally for Svetlana
Maria was the symbol of the women's
protest she inspired belarusians to
protest her symbol is a red lipstick and
this symbol became also the inspiration
for many women who were on the streets
and right now this symbol is in jail is
incarcerated a struggling for her life
we know very little information because
lukashenkas and KGB sensors they don't
give information neither to lawyers nor
to family we know that she's alive at
this moment we know that she her state
of health is a stably critical she got
surgery yesterday but she was delivered
to the surgery directly from the
punishment cell punish Southern prison
where she is serving her 11 years
sentence and funny from what you know
about the way the the prison system
works in Belarus for someone a prominent
prisoner like Maria to be taken from
prison to a hospital immediately for
surgery what does that tell you then
about
her health and and I mean it must be
very serious right
Belarus prisons is one of the worst
places in the world in in the prison you
don't have access to information to
Media you can't meet or see your
relatives the only communication with
outside world is the lawyer who can
visit you rarely but not when you're in
a punishment cell people are often from
prisons brought to this to to outside to
the small yard near the prison and kept
Frozen
for hours many people many prisoners
including women are tortured just a few
days ago we heard them statement from
Human Rights activist who is political
prisoner right now and she said that she
she was beaten she was humiliated
by lukashenka's guards and we don't know
what they did to Maria because 10 days
ago she was put in such punishment cell
what information they wanted from her
what they were trying to do to her let's
not forget she is one of the biggest
enemy is to lukashenka
yeah it's a very good point and we know
that you will stay on this and hopefully
we will have positive information sooner
rather than later product we appreciate
your time tonight thank you
thank you